for many hundreds of years
mathematicians have been fascinated by
the infinite sum which we would call a
series of one plus one-half plus
one-third plus one-fourth and you just
keep adding on and on and on forever and
this is interesting on many layers one
it just feels like something that would
be interesting to explore it's one over
one plus one over two plus one over
three that each of these terms are
getting smaller and smaller they're
approaching zero but when you add them
all together these infinite number of
terms do you get a finite number or does
it diverge do not get a finite number
this also shows up in music and this
actually might have been one of the
early motivations for studying this
series
where if you have a fundamental
note a fundamental frequency in music
and the point of this video isn't to
teach you too much about music but if
you have a fundamental note that might
be a pure a or something like that i'm
just showing you one of its wavelengths
obviously you would keep going like that
and this is a hand-drawn version so it's
not perfect
the harmonics are the frequencies the
overtones that at least to our ear
reinforce that a and what's true about
the harmonics are that they will be one
half of the wavelength of a in which
case it might look something like this
so this would
be a harmonic of a it has half of the
wavelength of a and notice it gets it
when it finishes its second
full waveform it ends again right at the
same time that the wavelength of a ends
and then it would be another harmonic
would be something that has a third the
wavelength of a fourth of a wavelength
of a and if you look at a lot of musical
instruments or what sounds good to our
ears they're playing not just the
fundamental tone but a lot of the
harmonics but anyway that was a
long-winded way of justifying why this
is called the harmonic series
harmonic
on harmonic series and in a in a future
video we will prove that and i don't
want to ruin the punch line but this
actually diverges and i will come up
with general rules for when things that
look like this might converge or diverge
but the harmonic series in particular
diverges so if we were to write it so in
sigma form we would write it like this
we're going from n equals 1 to infinity
of 1 over n
now another interesting thing is well
what if we were to throw in some
exponents here so we already said and
i'll just rewrite it doesn't hurt to
rewrite it and get more familiar with it
this right over here is the harmonic
series 1 over 1 which is just 1 plus 1
over 2 plus 1 over 3
so on and so forth but what if we were
to raise each of these denominators to
say the
second power so you might have something
that looks like this
where you have from n equals 1 to
infinity of 1 over n
to the second power well then it would
look like this would be 1 over
1 squared which is 1. and we could just
write that first term as 1 plus 1 over 2
squared which would be 1 4 plus 1 over 3
squared which is 1 9 and then you could
go on and on
for ever
forever and then you could generalize it
you could say hey all right what if we
wanted to have a general class of series
that we were to describe like this going
from n equals 1 to infinity of 1 over n
to the p where p could be any exponent
so for for example well the way this
would play out is this would be
1 plus 1 over 2 to the p plus 1 over 3
to the p plus 1 over 4 to the p and it
doesn't just have to be an integer value
it could be some p could be one half in
which case you would have 1 plus 1 over
the square root of 2 plus 1 over the
square root of 3. this entire class of
series and of course harmonic series is
a special case where p is equal to one
this is known as p series
so these are known as p
series and i try to remember it because
it's p for for the power that you are
raising this denominator to you could
also view it as erasing the whole
expression to it because one to any
exponent is still going to be one
but i hinted a little bit that maybe
some of these converge and some of these
diverge and we're going to prove it in
future videos but the general principle
is if p is greater than 1
then we are going to converge
and that makes sense intuitively because
that means that the terms are are
getting smaller and smaller fast enough
because the larger the exponent for that
denominator that means that the
denominator is going to get bigger
faster which means that the fraction is
going to get smaller faster and if p is
less than or equal to one and of course
when p is equal to one we're dealing
with the famous harmonic series that's a
situation in which we
diverge and we will prove these things
in future videos